have you yourself having been involved
in this closely at that time do you have
an opinion what happened yes I have an
opinion but what do you think exactly
what militare said is they shot him with
a high-powered rifle and they had a
patsy all set up who was silly all round
saw how deeply believe that and I hate
to say it that this thing assassination
of the president went to the highest
position in our government that there
was a coup to take him out of power
because not only was he heard two
southerners but him one to pull out a
Vietnam in the morning to go back to the
standard as so far as a monetary system
was concerned all of these things would
have severely crippled the money
Powell's here in the United States so he
had to be eliminated